mientras unos pasaron la noche en
refugios subterráneos
otros cargan sus pertenencias y se
apresuran resignados a abandonar ucrania
ante los ataques del ejército ruso en
diversos puntos del país como esta mujer
que se dirige en bicicleta a la frontera
húngara
tuvimos que dejar atrás todo el trabajo
nuestra vida es una sensación terrible
dejar tu casa ni te imaginas cómo me
siento ahora
una imagen que se repite de moldavia a
polonia los países centroeuropeos se
disponen a instalar puntos de recepción
de refugiados en sus fronteras a la
espera de una gran afluencia de
ucranianos que están intentando huir por
tierra en las últimas horas absorto
melián people hasta 5 millones de
personas pueden huir de ucrania a otros
países si la situación se agrava sedado
we have según acnur más de 100.000
personas se han desplazado de sus
hogares desde el inicio de la ofensiva
del kremlin sobre ucrania una amenaza
que afecta también a los menores de edad
como muchos de ustedes saben la
operación militar en ucrania ha supuesto
una amenaza inmediata para la vida y el
bienestar de los 75 millones de niños
pero no todos pueden salir el gobierno
ucraniano ha restringido el paso de sus
fronteras a los hombres de entre 18 y 60
años que deben tomar las armas para
luchar contra las tropas rusas las
estaciones de tren y bus las mujeres
abrazan entre lágrimas a sus hijos y
maridos quienes están unos 100 discos o
joyas
debido a la ley marcial todos los
militares obligados todos los hombres
deben luchar por el país por la paz para
evitar los ataques de las fuerzas
enemigas y para que todo esté bien
nosotros y los niños debemos salir de
ucrania
la comisión europea anunció que está
coordinando la ayuda de emergencia para
la acogida de refugiados y diversos
países occidentales han ofrecido visas
para los ucranianos